a clash over morality and perceived
influence on young minds dozens of
children were kept out of Anderton Park
School in Birmingham by parents who are
concerned the school is promoting
same-sex relationships there was no
official protest today but when MP Jess
Phillips came to lend her support to the
school she clashed with key campaigners
I will say to this young man who is
leading this particular protest is you
are harming the community that I grew up
in you are harming Muslim Muslim
community how come you have not
supported the 300 parenting here for the
last four weeks that you are damaging
the reputation of the Muslim community
the behavior of the school and towards
parents is coming across as Lama for
protest has claimed that six hundred
pupils didn't attend but the school told
us 35% that's roughly 240 of their
pupils didn't turn up the head teacher
told me parents were being intimidated
at the school gates there were group of
parents and various different positions
around the school
blocking the pavement so were my deputy
head winner and actor actually asked
them to move to allow parents to bring
in their children and they were
harassing people sarah hewitt clarkson
feels the Department of Education is
part responsible for what's happening
they've allowed parents to think that
parents tell schools what to do and
parents tell schools which books they
can have which books they can't have
what they can say what they can't say
the education secretary did lend his
support the school today speaking on Sky
News religion itself is a protected
characteristic under thee under the
equalities legislation but it is
important that in school you know
children are growing up knowing about
modern Britain
knowing about the country in which in
which they're going to become adults
LGBT campaigners put posters on the
school fence in response to the protest
the head teacher here says that she
feels like this school is under siege
that they are holding the fort for
British schools everywhere that
campaigners are using it as a test case
that could be rolled out across the
country but the protesters say that
they're the ones who are being bullied
and ignored we under siege viñoly under
siege from school far we are getting
under siege from everyone now
however some Muslim parents here don't
want the school to be swayed I was
greeted myself by one of the protesters
sending parents away saying go home go
home don't bring your kids to school
today and I said to them at the end of
the day our kids their education is
important there have been calls for an
exclusion zone to be set up around the
school so that children at the center of
this cultural social and moral storm
don't have to be reminded of it every
time they walk to school Jason Farrell
Sky News